Christina Aguilera opening up about body
image and her one-time rivalry with
Britney Spears oh god where do we even
began check out Christina working it in
all white on the October issue of
Cosmopolitan inside the mag the singer
gets real about her feelings on being
pit against Spears when she released her
stripped album and they viewed a more
provocative look quote I remember being
hurt by these commercials on NTV pitting
Britney Spears as the good girl and me
as the bad girl it's like if I'm going
to be demure and innocent that's okay
but if I'm going to just be myself I'm
trouble I like to change it up after
rebranding herself when dirty Christina
says she now appreciates the skin she's
in quote I love the female body and I
think it's something to be proud of
dirty was extremely controversial at the
time but it would be nothing now I hope
I paved the way as for Christina's love
life it's pretty tamed she prefers
dating men who aren't in the limelight
quote I've had opportunities but it
isn't my style to date another person in
the business
the 37 year old has been in a
relationship with Matthew rut lers since
2010 when they met on set of burlesque
he was a production assistant on the
film
[Music]